hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to I can't believe it's not
gambling have you ever liked loot boxes
have you ever liked putting real life
money on fake life things have you ever
like putting your real life money in so
that you can get digital goods well now
your life can be more fulfilled than you
ever knew it could be so this game
basically is trying to show you whoa
okay what's not beer oh hey I got an
achievement I don't know what not not
battlefield at war what did I do oh it's
like smacking oh wow
I died okay oh oh I need money I need
money to open my loot boxes oh I can get
hats and skins this is my least favorite
thing about any game but here it seems
amazing okay open loop box
whoa holy [ __ ] alright okay so that
let's keep the sell one rare that was a
rare I didn't know that's so one trash
wait hold a second here oh they're all
rare although keep that keep it I gotta
sell that okay oh that right okay wow
wow wow wow
oh so deep I'm getting so many
achievements I love myself oh here we go
yeah it's about to happen Wow okay
what is this doing for Oh equip this
trash can Christmas no I want a trashcan
lid hey I'm honestly confused this game
is actually fun all right Lou open it up
yeah yeah oh boy oh that feels good whoa
hey hey what the hell are you all right
I'll take that
so all oh it's just a bunch of Commons a
cell ball get out of here yeah don't
that feels so I want who's happy over
there all right shut up a little bit I
gotta get more trash excuse me I'm very
busy
why is it an epic I don't understand why
is it an FL syllable okay so one epic I
did it I did it I feel great about
myself oh all right
that's an epic all right I'll sell them
all I'm making moola now God want it I
really wanted I'm gonna keep this game
oh look at me wait here Wow look at me
what legend oh just look at that trash
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
jeez so funny
III I honestly download this game
expecting it to be a stupid little like
oh but it's so funny it's a bunch of
garbage it's so into this this is a
bunch of garbage stupid oh yes yes yes
yes yes what hi hello yes I want you
alright so all this garbage wait wow
I've got a little trash can oh all right
yeah good why am i so happy about it's a
different holiday version but it's okay
I do want it but I want to move on so
I'll sell it all I'm sure if I just if I
sell them I'll get more later it's fine
it's fine give me some good stuff come
on give me some good stuff good stuff
good stuff good stuff good stuff
oh well good stuff good stuff now boring
boring boring boring give me money give
me money give me fuel give me fire give
me that which I desire garbage
oh it's a holiday I don't need it I
don't need it I'm stronger than you I
can buy another one a cardboard box yes
open tiny box Tim what's inside of you
yes
it's better be good ah it's garbage sell
them all I put real money it is how
about the real money all right give me
something good
give me the flavor of something special
this is the flavor of [ __ ] it's got
a tiny bugs on it I'm keeping you sell
all right here we go it's good
why do you have a green glowing dildo
look at you there's such a good box but
that's got a tiny box
oh I'm keeping that box I'm selling all
the other ones okay all right you my
collection I have a problem I definitely
have a problem you wait oh wait no yes
oh look at you this is a terrible box I
don't like this box great is a thousand
you must be this rich - I don't want to
ride that
alright go go go time out tip oh that
feels good that's good I don't know the
whole point of loot boxes right is to
make it feel really good this game ah
spec see who this game makes I like the
red trim on that one I'm gonna keep that
one oh yeah collected would come you
know I did oh yeah give me that red trim
ah sorry I meant to say red tape ooh
blue trim oh yes oh yes
is that a galaxy box it's chrome galaxy
box I love it I love it DynaVox tip it's
translucent yes what's even the moral of
the story here whoa nice one but not a
good enough to keep
I don't know what the moral the story
here is the moral is that this is
legitimately fun just opening boxes but
I guess the whole thing of putting real
money into loot boxes it is kind of
gambling it is it is kind of gambling it
is a little bit gambling it's just a
little gambling that's good stuff I need
more money I need more money give me
more money come on give me the good [ __ ]
pop I don't need it I don't need it I
need it
perhaps no yes I did it right okay hang
on wait yeah oh look at my box everybody
at home look at my box
everybody ignore how weird that
statement is look at my box all right
hang out I'm gonna play this whoo how
much Oh 280 that's not as good it's just
as good okay all right I got to sell the
first crates I get I have to what else
is there present that [ __ ] ship
garbage animu whoo that sounds good
treasure wait let me play a game whoa
sweet okay all right now let's get some
oh yeah open up please sweet crate sweet
crate of mind terrible head I don't like
it I don't like any of this
just one of the basic [ __ ] crate gotta
sell yeah I got to move on I got to get
to the next level I got to ascend I
can't I can't stay here - I'm so close
to the next level I just gotta catch the
next level then I'll be happy then I'll
be happy with my life then I'll be happy
with what I'm doing in my life
that'll be happy I started this episode
so calm I didn't know what I was getting
myself I do not crippling addiction it's
getting more rare I know it's getting
more red there's no way it was this rare
before I was getting a lot more
high-level stuff before I ignore that
those are only rares they're not
legendaries or epics
that's pretty good all right pretty good
give me something good give me something
good
yes yes okay
all right I will play one game but we
have not - oh yeah ah I was just oh [ __ ]
all right it's fine it's fine gotta go
back to the loot I got presents now oh
yeah you're gonna give me some good
aren't you you're gonna give me some
good no shut up stop shaking at me yes a
holiday themed presents I like the way
you shake at me but I like the way you
move you know what I'm just gonna keep
this tiny head oh yes evil that feels
good yes oh so you sell them so at all
yes this is the good stuff this is the
good stuff yes I do
I have a problem how about you I have a
problem I oh boo I have a problem I'm a
boo oh that's so good I want it so badly
Oh
oh it's so good it's so good
look at that books next level it's a
ship I don't even know all right
whatever it's fine
okay open this bad boy up come on give
me someone good gimme something good
gimme good good no that's not good you
said nice mood I want to move but I like
this moon the yellows actually I like it
like oh yeah yes yes I want that yes I
absolutely want yes I want that oh that
I didn't even think I got dad that's not
what it looks like what I love it yeah
oh so good I'm crippling ly addicted
oh that's butt-ugly yeah that is I have
to have that okay all right you know
what I'm gonna I'm gonna stop I'm gonna
stop oh damn I look good as much as I
want to go to the animu and the treasure
I just I can't do it I must stop or else
I'll be here forever okay imma keep
going
oh oh oh yes
god I'm so weak I was so close why is
there a red why is that
wait I said why is that red what is that
red hey why is there a red no no that's
all about them okay all right
oh I love my ship so bad
okay alright having up for the next
level all right here we go
I'm gonna play this game I am gonna play
this game I'm gonna play this game I'm
gonna play this nice nice nice nice nice
two million two million I like it
go go go go oh yeah oh yeah that's good
stuff nice and mu ho ho ho ho oh whoa
whoa whoa whoa okay keep it keeping
Celie welly hahaha oh yeah did that and
and god I'm so beautiful
Oh Frick a lack of frakkin Decca oh man
help me please please please Oh anybody
watching I have a problem I guess was it
didn't choke I can't stop yeah god I
literally can't stop for my look so good
Oh God I've made it to Velasco I made it
the old why is it slanty ah tits alright
whatever it's fine
this is where the real funs at
hahaha Oh a box in a box in a treasure
box boxes inside my box I guess nobody
boxes are my bags not today
nope don't need that need the money give
me the money give me the money come it's
coming I feel I feel good stuff it was a
garbage stuff give me the good stuff
give me give me the good stuff
no not crumb maybe you got a space one
in there no you got us come on you know
what you want to give me you giving it
to me sir shut up and give it to me I'll
be able to sell all the things that I
own yes no give me a good box I want a
good skin good skin and please give me
skin yes yes yes oh yes there's nothing
else I have everything I have everything
I am done I have to be everything I
could ever want
I'm so happy look how happy I am okay so
that is the end of this game I'm gonna
leave this here before I lose my
officially this is bad I can't believe
it's not gambling thank you everybody so
much rule she gets that fall into a bit
of despair forever and ever but thank
you so much you want to gamble your life
away check out the link in the
description below I'll provide the game
down there and as always let's see you
in the next video
[Music]